hi herzlich Willkommen zu ztf heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid im Update
gucken wir an diesem Donnerstag wieder
auf die Lage der Ukraine an einem
Großteil der Front gibt es wenig
Bewegung und der Artillerie
Munitionsmangel der wird zu einem immer
größeren Problem und gleichzeitig hat
sich dann die EU heute auf ukrainehilfen
in Höhe von 50 Milliarden Euro geeinigt
die sollen bis 2027 gelten der
ungarische Ministerpräsident Orban hat
seine Blockade aufgegeben lasst uns auch
direkt mal einen Blick auf die neuesten
Bilder aus der Ukraine werfen die sollen
die Zerstörung einer mit Raketen
bewaffneten russischen Corvette im
Westen der Krim zeigen das Kriegsschiff
soll nach Angaben des ukrainischen
Verteidigungsministeriums von
marinedrohnen getroffen und versenkt
worden sein und auch diese Meldung ist
für die ukrainische Armee wichtig die
stellvertretende US Außenministerin
bestätigte die Lieferung einer neuen
hightechwaffe die sogenannten glsdb
präzisionsbomben hier Bilder des
Herstellers seien auf dem Weg an die
Front ja und was diese neue Hightech
Waffe für die Ukraine bedeutet und wie
es an der Front aussieht das bespreche
ich heute mit militärökonom Markus K von
der Militärakademie ETH Zürich und wie
es um die Berichterstattung um einen
möglichen Machtkampf zwischen Präsident
selenski und dem chef saluschni steht
und wie es den Menschen in der Ukraine
geht darüber spreche ich mit ZDF
reporterin Anne brü die uns live aus der
Ukraine zugeschaltet ist und wie immer
hier bei heute live spreche ich auch mit
euch wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema habt oder
eure Kommentare und Meinungen mit uns
teilen wollt dann macht das wie immer
gerne hier im Youtube Chat oder per Mail
an die unten eingeblendete Adresse jetzt
schalten wir erst einmal direkt zu
militärökonom Markus Kolb nach Zürich
guten Abend Herr Kolb hallo guten Abend
ja lassen Sie uns zuerst erstm lassen
sie uns erstmal auf den Süden der Front
schauen und auf die Bilder dieses
versenkten russischen Kriegsschiffes da
haben wir die Bilder gerade eben gesehen
was bedeutet denn dieser Erfolg jetzt
strategisch für die Ukraine ja sie
kennen vielleicht das Zitat aus kill
bill you and I have unfinished business
und genau darum ging es eigentlich also
diese Corvette die ianovitz die hier
versenkt worden ist das war eines der
Schiffe die seit Ende 22 und vor allem
im letzten Sommer also im Sommer 23 äh
die Seeblockade gegen die Ukraine
durchgesetzt haben also gegen die
ukrainischen Getreideexporte ne was dazu
führte dass kein ukrainisches Schiff aus
Odessa auslaufen konnte und eben die die
ivanovitz das ist so ein raketenschiff
ähm also sprich ein ein Schiff mit D mit
mit raketenbestück das eben großen Teil
von dieses seekorridors sperren konnte
und das hat man hier rausgenommen ähm es
ist in in mehrfacherweise
bemerkenswert das Ganze ist also wenn
wir diesem dem Video und dem den Angaben
des des Militärgeheimdienstes glauben
können dann ist das etwas außerhalb von
donuslav passiert donuslav ist der
größte See m in auf der Krim also der
liegt da an der Nordspitze der Krim man
sieht sie auf der Karte so ein bisschen
genau also da wo jetzt hier diese
explosions Grafik da ist genau da ist es
passiert
und zwar etwas etwas außerhalb also ähm
auf auf offener See sozusagen und es
waren mehrere seedrohnen die das
koordiniert
ähm angegriffen haben das ist also schon
bemerkenswert weil man würde ja erwarten
ähm dass eine Region die so nah an
diesem Hafen bzw diesem inlandssee
doneslav liegt dass es da electronic
Warfare gibt und entsprechende
Sicherungsmaßnahmen für die Schiffe ähm
ist aber nicht erfolgt ähm die iitz hat
noch versucht so ein bisschen zu
manövrieren und und denen zu entkommen
aber hat es nicht geschafft weil der
Angriff eben von mehreren drohen und
mehreren Richtungen gleichzeitig kam
die Ukraine hat gleichzeitig also
wenige Stunden vorher ein missile Schlag
gegen die Airbase von belbeck die liegt
etwas südlicher etwa also sprich etwas
nördlich von sevasterp durchgeführt
möglicherweise hängt das damit zusammen
also dass dass die Russen abgelenkt
waren und gedacht haben jetzt jetzt
kommt wieder so ein so ein typischer
missile strike gegen Airbase und und
damit eben nicht so sehr auf die auf die
Mari Verteidigung geschaut haben ist
möglich ähm aber ja das ist es ist
wieder so ein ein weiterer Schritt in in
dem ständigen dauerwitz ne ein ein Land
das das keine Marine hat und und keine
Seestreitkräfte versenkt ein russisches
Schiff nach dem anderen
es ist denke ich eine Demonstration
wozu koordinierte drohenaktionen
mittlerweile fähig sind ich erinnere
mich z.B an einen Vorfall bei der Brücke
von Kersch da hat die Ukraine ja auch
versucht mit sedrohen anzugreifen
allerdings nicht so erfolgreich also die
wurden hauptsächlich erkannt und und
abgewährt aber bei diesem mal ist eben
die die Koordination und und das das ist
deutlich höhere technologieniveau
bemerkenswert ja sie haben es gerade
angesprochen es ist nicht das erste
Schiff was da versenkt wurde hier fragt
gerade jemand aus der Community wie
viele Kriegsschiffe hat Russland
überhaupt noch oder das hängt davon ab
welche Flotte sie
betrachten also die die baltische Flotte
ist eine der kineren
aber bei bei der Baltischen Flotte klar
da können sie sagen das ist jetzt nicht
nicht wirklich im Kampfgebiet ä die
einzige die wir jetzt im Moment konkret
betrachten ist die Schwarzmeerflotte und
da geht's nicht so sehr um die Anzahl
der Schiffe sondern da geht's darum wie
sicher sind die Landeplätze oder wie
sicher sind
sind die Häfen oder und was die Ukraine
damit eigentlich versucht zu
demonstrieren ist zu sagen egal wo ihr
eure Schiffe hintut auf der Krim Sie sie
nicht sicher es gab ja auch den den
Schlag gegen diese be beiden russischen
U-Boote die bei Sevastopol im Dock lagen
und ich denke das ist eher so zu sehen
dass man den Russen also klar macht
wenn ihr eure Schiffe da liegen lasst
dann haben sie keine Überlebenschance
wir werden Sie nach und nach alle
rausnehmen und es gibt ja bereits Pläne
der Russen ein Teil der
schwarzmeherflotte abzuziehen nach
Abchasien also sprich in den besetzten
Teil Georgiens dort an die Küstenlinie
m und ich ich denke so ist es zu
verstehen also im im Rahmen der größeren
ukrainischen Methode eben die den Russen
klarzum machen dass ihre Position
logistisch nicht zu halten ist ja und
wir bleiben noch mal bei diesem Thema da
gibt's nämlich gerade noch eine Frage
aus der Community hier fragt jemand wie
viele Schiffe pro Jahr baut den
eigentlich die Ukraine gibt's da Zahlen
zu da da müsste ich etwas ausholen also
die die Ukraine hatte mal
Seestreitkräfte die sind dann allerdings
mit durch einen
Teilungsvertrag weitgehend an Russland
übereignet worden die Ukraine hat im
Moment keine eigene schiffsproduktion
soweit ich weiß sie hat ein paar
kleinere Schiffe die werden
hauptsächlich für Küstenwache und und
sowas eingesetzt aber sie hat keine
keine kampffähige Flotte äh im
eigentlichen Sinn sie wird eine solche
aber natürlich aufbauen
nach Kriegsende oder schon während
während der der Endphase des kriegeswahl
natürlich klar ist äh wenn Sie sich mit
einem ultranationalistischen Russland äh
als als Nachbar im Schwarzen Meer aus
inandersetzen müssen dann werden sie gar
nicht drum rumkommen äh die aufzubauen
also das ist im Moment noch nicht so
wirklich ein Thema das wichtige Thema
für die Ukraine ist vor allem dass sie
den getreidekorridor offen halten kann
äh eben damit ihre Schiffe äh das
Schwarze Meer befahren und und Getreide
exportieren können das macht sie aber
nicht mit einer eigenen Flotte weil es
zu lange dauern würde im Moment die zu
bauen sondern eben mit solchen
indirekten Mitteln also sprich mit
missils äh mit mit seedrohnen und und
macht damit der russischen Flotte klar
äh ihr könnt euch hier nicht halten also
lasst uns besser in Ruhe sonst werdet
ihr
abgeschossen ja und von diesem Erfolg
der Ukrainer gehen wir mal weiter an der
Front denn an großen Teilen der Front
sieht die Lage ja recht unverändert aus
wir gucken mal in den Süden nach krinki
die Lage auf dem Ostufer des nipro ist
für die Ukrainer schwierig wir sehen das
hier gerade auf der Karte und der
Oberbefehlshaber saluschni der hatte
zuletzt angekündigt dort bald Kräfte
abzuziehen dort ist die Hoffnung also
nicht allzu groß
oderch das kann man so nicht sagen weil
so viele Kräfte stehen dort nicht also
bei bei kinki das sind etwa 400 Mann die
sich dort wirklich Lokal aufhalten die
haben mal übergesetzt so ab dem ab dem
Sommer 23 mit mit einzelnen booten und
haben mal getestet wie weit können sie
eigentlich gehen
m und
der der Hauptteil der Arbeit dort wird
eigentlich gemacht von
drohnenoperateuren also Spezialkräften
die entlang der versorgungsachsen M14
und M17 das sind die beiden Lokalen
Landstraßen den Russen dort das Leben
schwer machen das überraschende ist
eigentlich dass diese Operation in kinky
überhaupt funktioniert
also spricht die die Russen haben im
Moment dem nicht wirklich was
entgegenzusetzen weil es es gibt nur
diese eine kleine Küstenstraße die da
entlang führt die ist nicht wesentlich
befestigt durch Gräben oder sonstige
Verteidigungsstellung also nicht wie die
surowikinlinie im donbas weil man gesagt
hat na ja gut also da da schützt uns der
Fluss und die kommen sowieso nicht
drüber und amphibische Operation bringt
auch nichts ne aber so einfach ist es
nicht sie sehen da den großen weißen
Fleck das sind die olke Dünen und die
bilden so ein großes natürliches
Hindernis die beiden Straßen die ich
erwähnt habe die müssen die umfahren und
die nördliche davon die M17 die ist
bereits unter ukrainischer
artilleriekontrolle also sie müssen sich
das so vorstellen stehen nicht nur diese
Leute in krinki sondern gegenüber also
auf dem nördlichen Ufer des nipro da
steht die ukrainische Artillerie und
schießt über den Fluss und ähm das sind
also soweit ich auf der Karte gesehen
habe immer noch vier marinebrigaden die
dort stehen also die auch spezialisiert
sind auf diese Art von von Kriegführung
von Flussübergängen und ähm ja natürlich
ist es unrealistisch jetzt zu glauben
dass das hier ein großer amphibischer
Übergang oder sowas stattfindet weil
dafür hat die Ukraine nicht die
notwendige geländekontrolle aber sie
kann den Russen das Leben schwer machen
und sie sozusagen ähm verführen immer
mal wieder gepanzerte Fahrzeuge oder
infanterieverbände reinzuschicken und
die werden dann rausgenommen das ist das
eigentlich überraschende ne weil dort
unten stehen also alleine in diesen
südwestlichen Abschnitt mindestens
sieben russische Brigaden also rein
materialmäßig sollte das ein Leichtes
sein diese Leute rauszunehmen und das
bemerkenswert ist eigentlich dass die
Russen es trotzdem nicht
hinbekommen dass jetzt dort aber Truppen
abgezogen werden oder zumindest
das angekündigt wird das ist jetzt aber
auch kein Zeichen dafür dass von dort
aus jetzt eine große Offensive geplant
ist nein also ich denke dass in in in
krinki das ist eigentlich so ein so ein
typisches abnutzungsmanöver ne also die
die ukrainische Strategie ist ja
unverändert die die Taktik der der 1000
Bienenstiche also spricht man
man versucht eben durch durch
abnutzungsstrategie ähm die Russen zu
zwingen immer mehr von ihrem Material
einzusetzen
bis irgendwann ihre Reserven
aufgebraucht sind ich denke so ist es zu
verstehen wenn sie jetzt sagen also ich
we ich weiß nicht wer das gesagt hat
oder oder wie glaubwürdig das ist aber
wenn sie sagen sie ziehen diese Leute ab
dann würde das heißen sie können sie
nicht mehr versorgen ne also sie sie
kriegen keinen logistischen Nachschub
mehr hin ähm oder die Leute können sich
dort nicht halten ähm ich weiß zu wenig
über die lokale taktische Situation um
jetzt zu beurteilen ob das irgendein
Gerücht ist äh oder ob das stimmt aber
ich ich sehe jetzt nicht unbedingt den
Grund ähm warum man die Leute abziehen
könnte also solange sie mit diesen
minimalen Mitteln die wir hier gerade
sehen also das sind wirklich nur leicht
bewaffnete Spezialkräfte mit Drohnen
aber solange sie eben äh sowas machen
können also mit mit einer FPV Drone
nehmen Sie hier ein schweres gepanzertes
Fahrzeug raus solange würde es schon
Sinn machen die Leute da zul lassen mhm
den Abzug angekündigt hatte der
oberbefehshaber saluschni wir gehen aber
mal weiter am Frontverlauf in Richtung
Osten und gucken auf
aftiivka auch da haben wir eine Karte
und dort wird ja berichtet dass Russen
durch die Kanalisation eine Art
Durchbruch geschafft haben nicht direkt
in afdivka sondern südlich der Stadt
genau also man muss sich vorstellen
afdivka ist ja keine normale Kleinstadt
sondern eigentlich ein ein komplexes
untertunneltes verbunkertes System also
einer der der starken Punkte der der
sogenannten kontaktlinie seit 2015 schon
massiv ausgebaut das heißt mit mit
konventionellen Mitteln da irgendwo
durchzukommen selbst wenn sie extreme
Opfer bringen das ist sehr sehr
schwierig das haben die Russen blutig
lernen müssen schon im Januar 23 das
ganze Jahr 23 hindurch wie gesagt in
seit Oktober 23 bis bis in diese Tage
haben sie es immer wieder versucht sind
nicht durchgekommen mit schweren Mitteln
jetzt haben sie es auf eine andere Art
und Weise versucht nämlich indem sie ähm
ein ich weiß nicht wie viel es waren ich
glaube ein Bataillon eingeschleustt
haben durch durch solche Versorgungs ähm
oder Abwasser Rohre also nicht nicht
eigentlich durch die eigentlichen
Bunkeranlagen sondern sie sie nehmen
quasi die zivile Infrastruktur und und
versuchen sich da durchzuschneiden oder
durchzuschweißen bis sie an irgendeiner
Stelle rauskommen das ist ihnen auch
gelungen einige 100und Meter ähm
voranzukommen entlang ähm dieser äh
dieser Röhren bis die Ukrainer es
gemerkt haben und sie dann wieder
zurückgeworfen haben ähm also auf auf
allen Karten die die ich im Moment habe
ist das Ganze als contested also als als
graue Zone äh im Moment markiert ähm
aber ich weiß nicht falls das irgendein
großartiger infanri Vorstoß gewesen sein
sollte oder so geplant gewesen sein
sollte dann hat das nicht wirklich viel
gebracht mhm jetzt sind ja einige
Analysten in dieser Art des russischen
forstoßens dort äh um neben afdivka so
ein bisschen äh eine Strategie zumindest
ein langsames aber stetiges vorrücken zu
leisten was laut der Analyse einiger
Experten zur Aufgabe von afdka führen
könnte gehen sie damit ach Gott ja also
der Tod auf die jekas bzw der definitive
Verlust der der kontaktlinie das wird
schon seit seit ich glaube seit Sommer
22 diskutiert also ich sag dann immer
show me the
evidence natürlich ist ist das schwierig
auf die jifka zu halten gegen die
kontinuierlichen russchen Versuche ist
ist einzunehmen aber man muss da
natürlich sehen das Verhältnis von
Material und Menschen die Russland da
hinein wirrft versus
Geländegewinne und da muss ich ehrlich
sagen also bisher bisher fehlen mir
wirklich die Daten wo ich sagen würde
auf die jifka ist ist nicht mehr zu
halten also da das das wäre der Fall
wenn sie am
Nordrand wirklich nachhaltig und mit
massivem Material die Bahnlinie
überwinden könnten oder wenn Sie das Kok
Werk ähm komplett erobern würden oder
wenn sie im Süden bis zu der zweiten
Hauptkreuzung vorstoßen würden also dann
dann vielleicht aber das ist bisher
nicht passiert und wie gesagt also
m die die Russen haben halt das
entscheidende Element nicht nämlich das
Element der Überraschung oder der
Initiative die Ukrainer wissen ganz
genau was sie vorhaben
ähm sie sitzen in dieser gut ausgebauten
Verteidigungsstellung also es es ist
vielleicht möglich dass auf die jefka
irgendwann mal taktisch aufgegeben wird
wenn man sagt okay die Russen haben
jetzt so viel da reing geopfert
und jetzt jetzt können wir die Front
begradigen weil sie sehen ja der das das
ragt wie so eine Tasche in die russische
Front hinein aber selbst sowas das
würden sie also nur sagen wenn wenn auf
dieivka nicht mehr zu halten wäre und im
Moment erfüllt auf dieka eben noch ein
wichtigen Punkt es hält nämlich
versorgungskorridore offen die wichtig
sind für diesen ganzen Frontabschnitt
also insbesondere bei bei iSki und
solange solange den Russen nicht
wirklich was besseres einfällt und das
das kann ich im Moment nicht sehen äh
soange wird auf die jivka sicher nicht
aufgegeben ähm und solange müssen die
Russen erstmal den Beweis erbringen dass
sie in der Lage sind es zu erobern ja
sie haben gerade schon die äh durchaus
verlustreichen Kämpfe angesprochen für
die Russen und Ihr Gerät und das zeigen
auch Bilder etwas weiter südlich bei
Novum schayivka was ist dort zu
sehen genau wir wir hier Nov michelke
ist etwa 35 km südwestlich von donjzk
ähm wir sehen den den alten Fehler der
Russen wieder also nach dem Motto lernen
wir jemals irgendwas dazu Antwort nein
wir fahren in einer gepanzerten Kolonne
und sie sehen genau eine Fahrspur ne wo
die Fahrzeuge hintereinander fahren
sehen Sie zu Beginn des Videos ähm und
ähm sie sehen sie fahren über offenes
Feld also es gibt nicht mal treelines es
gibt keine Deckung es es gibt gar nichts
ja also hier sehen wir wie die Fahrzeuge
hintereinander fahren auf auf dieser auf
dieser Straße und die werden natürlich
sofort aufgeklärt durch die drohen äh
die drohen übermitteln die Koordinaten
an die Artillerie und Sie werden sofort
rausgenommen sie sehen wie präzise diese
Schläge erfolgen also das war das war
wirklich so ein so ein typischer
Fleischwolf innerhalb von 3 Stunden
haben sie zehn gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
verloren da da kann man sich dann schon
mal fragen ähm ob die die russischen
Truppen jemals irgendwas dazu lernen
ähm das das ist so ein bisschen ähm ein
ein Effekt den wir an verschiedenen
Punkten der Front gesehen haben we sie
die Russen versuchen im Moment äh
dezentral anzugreifen an an vielen
verschiedenen Punkten gleichzeitig ähm
und die Ukrainer machen eigentlich das
gleiche also dezentrale Aktionen vor
allem mit Drohnen ebenfalls an an vielen
verschiedenen Punkten aber dieser dieser
eine Verlust der war wirklich
bemerkenswert das war am am 30 Januar
ähm und tja man man sagt ja immer die
die Russen lernen dazu oder die Russen
werden besser das stimmt punktuell auch
also in in manchen Bereichen sind sie
besser geworden aber
ähm das immer noch diese dilettantischen
Aktionen passieren das das zeigt mir
entweder dass dass sie nicht lernfähig
sind oder dass ihnen langsam die die
trainierten panzercws ausgehen also
sprich ähm dass da Leute drin sitzen den
ist halt mal kurz gezeigt worden wie man
gerade ausfährt und wie man die Granate
abfeuert aber ähm dass dass das Wahnsinn
ist in dieser Art und Weise über
ungedecktes Gelände vorzurücken äh das
hat man ihm vielleicht nicht gesagt
über Verlust von Gerät auf beiden Seiten
über Ausstattung und über diese neue
Hightech Waffe über sogenannte
präzisionsbumben sprechen wir gleich
noch dann haben wir auch Zeit eure
zahlreichen Fragen zu beantworten ich
sehe sie hier alle schon im Chat das
machen wir gleich mit Herrn KB bis
gleich und von dieser Diskussion
schalten wir jetzt erstmal rüber zur ztf
reporterin Anne Brühl die uns live aus
Odessa zugeschaltet ist in der Ukraine
guten Abend
Anne hallo guten Abend Anne es gibt ja
Medienberichte dass der ukrainische
Präsident selenski versucht den
Armeechef saluschni der ist eben schon
aufgekommen abzusetzen was ist dran an
diesen Berichten und woher kommt dieses
Machtgerangel was man da gerade
beobachtet also diese Geschichte die
köchelt hier schon seit ein paar Tagen
seit Montagabend genauer da hieß es
plötzlich auf mehreren telegramkanälen
selenski habe schon das Dekret zur
Absetzung von saluschni unterzeichnet
der habe das
abgelehnt das Dementi kam sofort muss
man sagen vom
Verteidigungsministerium auch aus dem
Präsidentenbüro aber damit war
keineswegs Ruhe eingekehrt sondern die
Geschichten rund um selenski saluschni
und den Machtkampf das köcheltierer
Oberbefehlshaber seit Anfang des Kriegs
ergilt sowas als das Master meint hinter
den ersten erfol folgen die Verteidigung
von Kiev von hakiv auch die Erfolge im
ersten Kriegsjahr die Eroberung weiter
Gebiete der Region harakiv die
Rückeroberung von Cherson und dann im
letzten Jahr da blieben diese
militärischen Erfolge ein wenig aus es
gab Berichte über Differenzen mit
selenski z.B um die Strategie rund um
bachmut die auch mit hohen ukrainischen
Verlusten verbunden war diese Offensive
die zuerst eine frühahs dann eine
Sommeroffensive wir werden wollte die
aber ja sollte die aber ja nie wirklich
vorankam das hat auch nicht dazu
beigetragen die Wogen zu Kletten und
dann hat saluschni eben auch mehrere
Interviews gegeben die offenbar nicht
abgesprochen waren das heißt dass es
gibt diese Differenzen und das ist
natürlich schlecht denn auf der einen
Seite ist das ein General mit Ambitionen
auch mit
politischenition das wird ihm immer
wieder nachgesagt auf der anderen Seite
ein Präsident der militärische Erfolg
nachweisen muss um auch wichtige
internationale Unterstützer bei der
Stange zu halten das ist also eine sehr
ungute Situation und viele hier glauben
dass das in den nächsten Tagen gelöst
werden muss und die Situation wie heute
Abend wo saluschni noch mal mit einem
Meinungsbeitrag bei CNN nachgelegt hat
die trägt nicht gerade zur Beruhigung
der Situation
bei ja von dieser politischen Ebene
kommen wir noch mal auf die
gesellschaftlich Ebene der Ukrainer und
Ukrainerinnen da gab es gestern einen
großen Gefangenen Austausch zwischen der
Ukraine und Russland das war der größte
Gefangenenaustausch seit Beginn des
Krieges Anne erzähl uns mal was bedeutet
so ein Gefangenenaustausch für die
Ukrainer und Ukrainerin wie wird der da
aufgenommen ja mit großer Freude mit der
Erleichterung denn natürlich ist die
Unterstützung für die die kämpfen für
die die in russische Gefangenschaft
geraten sind sehr groß wir haben gestern
Nachmittag in mikolajev getrh einer
Großstadt hier
anderthalb Stunden weg von Odessa und
die Leute haben alle auf ihre Handys
geguckt sich die Fotos angeschaut dieser
ukrainischen Soldaten die in ukrainische
Flaggen gehüllt waren und besonders der
Zeitpunkt ist natürlich auch
bemerkenswert denn vor einer Woche gab
es ja diesen Flugzeugabsturz bei
belgorot in Russland die Russen hatten
ja behauptet dass an Bord auch äh
ukrainische Kriegsgefangene gewesen sein
die Ukraine ähm verlangt nach wie vor
für Russland dafür Beweise vorzulegen es
war aber klar es waren äh ein Austausch
von Kriegsgefangenen geplant und viele
hier in der Ukraine hatten jetzt
befürchtet dass das alles in Stocken
gerät also mit diesem Austausch gestern
hat man gesehen da geht da offenbar dann
doch noch was
207 Soldaten sind zurückgekehrt in die
Ukraine und wie gesagt die Freude und
die Erleichterung die ist hier sehr groß
ja das sind auch wirklich bewegende
Bilder die wir da gerade gesehen haben
es wird ja auch immer wieder über eine
neue Mobilisierung der Ukraina
gesprochen viele an der Front sind nach
zwei Jahren erschöpft experten sagen
auch für den erhaltesstatus quo der
Front so wie wir ihn jetzt kennen da
brauche es auch Rotation und neue
Soldaten jetzt gibt es aktuell
Gesetzentwürfe die es ermöglichen sollen
deutlich mehr Ukrainer zu mobilisieren
als vorher wie ist denn da der aktuelle
Stand
ja es gab bereits einen Gesetzentwurf
Ende vergangenen Jahres den die
Regierung vorgelegt hat das Parlament
hat den quasi zurückgegeben jetzt seit
Dienstagabend gibt es einen neuen
Entwurf der Kernpunkte dafür ist dass
die
registrierungsregelungen für
Wehrpflichtige
transparenter gestaltet werden sollten
sollen im letzten Jahr gab es ja auch
einen Korruptionsskandal da ging es um
die regionalen
Rekrutierungsbüros das wehralter wurde
von 27 auf 25 heruntergesetzt es bleibt
aber dabei jeder der 18 oder älter ist
der kann sich freiwillig zum Dienst an
der Waffe melden es gibt ein paar
Neuerungen so soll z.B eine Art
Grundausbildung eingeführt werden die
zwei bis dre Monate dauern soll es soll
also niemand direkt an die Front
geschickt werden und dann steht in
diesem Entwurf auch drin dass die
Dienstzeit 36 Monate dauern soll das
wäre dann eine Beschränkung das ist eine
Forderung auf der einen Seite die viele
hier im Land haben gerade gibt es seit
Wochen die Proteste der Frauen hier im
Land ich war bei so einem solchen
Protest in Kiev da sind dann die Frauen
deren Brüder Söhne Väter an der Front
sind teilweise seit Kriegsbeginn und die
eben fordern dass jetzt auch mal andere
ran müssten dass die das dieses
Kriegsdienst auf mehrere und breitere
Schultern gestellt wird die Frauen sagen
ausdrücklich dass es keine Kritik an der
Regierung auch keine Kritik an der Armee
aber sie fordern eben eine größere Form
der Solidarität ein wenn man sich jetzt
dann diese 36 Monate anguckt dann ist
das aber auch etwas was den Frauen viel
zu lang ist in Kiev standen 18 Monate
auf den Plakaten das sei mehr als genug
sagten die Frauen mir mhm ja zum Thema
Mobilisierung gibt es eine Frage aus der
Community an Dich der fragt jemand auf
Youtube werden auch Ukrainer im Ausland
eingezogen und wenn ja wie viele wären
das ich glaube das ist nicht vorgesehen
es gibt auch sowieso einige Ausnahmen
also
z.B Männer die drei Kinder haben oder
mehr die werden nicht eingezogen der
whrdienst z. für Frauen und auch da gibt
es ja z.B ungefähr 40.000 aktive
Soldatinnen das ist nach wie vor
freiwillig es wird auch auf die
Familiensituation geguckt also dass z.B
Männer die allein erziehend sind nicht
zur zur zum Frontdienst eingezogen
werden also diese Ausnahmen gibt es und
wir machen noch mal einen kleinen
Schritt zurück und behandeln eine Frage
zum Gefangenen Austausch da fragt jemand
auf YouTube könnte dieser
Gefangenenaustausch ein Zeichen dafür
sein dass die Diplomatie mächtiger
werden
könnte ja das wäre vielleicht eine
Hoffnung und ich glaube das ist er
möglicherweise auch auf ukrainischer
Seite also wie gesagt diese diese
Rückkehr der Gefangenen auch z.B vieler
Soldaten die ja mariopol verteidigt
haben in diesem Stahlwerk gesessen haben
da wird immer genau drauf geguckt ob ob
die eben bei diesen austauschen dabei
sind aber
wie stark die Diplomatie ist das ist
wirklich schwer zu sagen und die Ukraine
betont eigentlich jederzeit dass dieser
Krieg sofort enden könnte nämlich dann
wenn Russland seine Aggressionen
einstellt es gibt ja auch diesen zehn
Punkte Friedensplan mit der
friedensformel von Präsident selenski
also ich glaube hier setzt man schon auf
Diplomatie hier hofft man auf Diplomatie
aber die große Frage ist ob das von
russischer Seite auch so gesehen
wird Anne danke dass du meine Fragen und
die Fragen aus der Community beantwortet
hast ich wünsche dir no einen schönen
Abend und alles Gute nach
Odessa ja und über die neue
hightechwaffe die ihr da hinter mir seht
und auch anderes militärisches Gerät
über die Auslastung über die aktuellen
Zahlen und Bestände sprechen wir jetzt
noch mal und zwar mit militärökonom
Markus Kolb der mir wieder zugeschaltet
ist
hallo ja diese sogenannte glsdb
präzisionsbombe die soll ja von den USA
an die Ukraine geliefert werden und
diese Bomben wurden bislang lediglich
getestet aber noch nie in einem Krieg
verwendet inwiefern könnten die denn
jetzt den Krieg vielleicht auch
entscheidend
beeinflussen also das stimmt so nicht gr
small Diana the bombs sind jetzt nicht
gerade eine neue Technologie sie sind
die Kombination von zwei verschiedenen
Elementen und die wurden auch
tatsächlich in Kampfeinsätzen bereits
verwendet äh also es wurden historisch
etwa 20.000 von denen gebaut und etwa
10000 wurden davon bislang in Kämpfen
eingesetzt also vielleicht kurz wie muss
man sich das vorstellen ähm diese Waffe
besteht aus zwei Teilen zum einen den
M26 Raketenmotor
und der stammt eigentlich aus einer
älteren Generation von von missiles und
diese missiles die haben früher
klastermunitionen getragen und als man
die klastermunition ähm durch das
Abkommen über die Streumunition
weitgehend verboten hat da haben alle
Länder ähm die diese alten M66 messils
hatten äh ihre äh Kluster Anteile
zerstört aber
ähm was man aufgehoben hat sind die
Raketenmotoren also spricht der der
Antrieb und auf der anderen Seite ähm
gibt es äh aus der amerikanischen
Entwicklung also genauer gesagt von von
Boeing und SAB ist das eine Entwicklung
ähm die sogenannte äh small diamet baom
also eine Bombe mit mit eher kleinem
Durchmesser und geringem Gewicht die
gbu39 und die war eigentlich vorgesehen
ähm für Kampfflugzeuge also spricht dass
sie eben weil sie klein und leicht ist
dass sie viele von denen an ein
Kampfflugzeug dran hängen könnten was
man jetzt gemacht hat ist so eine Art
Ikea ähm Bastelei das ist nicht neu da
kam man drauf so vor ungefähr 20 Jahren
äh wir könnten doch die beiden
kombinieren also wir nehmen den M26
Raketenmotor und Schrauben den sozusagen
an diese
äh an diese gbu39 dran und damit
erhalten wir eine missile die und für
die brauchen wir eben keine
Kampflugzeuge mehr sondern die können
wir abschießen und zwar erstens aus den
bestehenden Heß Systemen also die kennen
wir ja mittlerweile alle äh oder es gibt
sogar eine eigene abschlussvorrichtung
also ein ISO Container und mit der
können Sie das Ganze im Prinzip von
Schiffen oder von von irgendwelchen
landgestützten Punkten also egal wo
abfeuern und wir wir kennen mittlerweile
das heimassystem das große Problem des
heimasystem ist eben die begrenzte
Reichweite von maximal 80 kilomet also
von den von den Miss die die das
hemystem verschießt glsdb hat fast die
doppelte Reichweite von ungefähr 150 km
also Sie können ja zu Hause mal eine
Karte sich hernehmen und wenn sie vom
äußersten Punkt des Frontverlaufs
einfach Radius Zeichnen von 150 km dann
erreichen Sie also je nachdem wo sie
sind wenn sie im donb sind erreichen Sie
die russischen Verteidigungs und
logistiklinien und zwar in großer Tiefe
sie erreichen knapp das russische
Hauptquartier gennyesk auf der Krim sie
erreichen knapp JCO wenn Sie das Ganze
gegenüber von no kachowka aufstellen
also das ist schon mal ein riesen
Vorteil der zweite große Vorteil ist
eben die Stückzahl also nicht nur dass
man jetzt je nachdem welche Zahlen sie
lesen so zwischen 10 und 17 000 im
Moment noch an globalen Vorräten hat
sondern es gibt eben auch eine
bestehende Produktionslinie die man
jetzt an Boeing und und SA gegeben hat
das heißt also die Dinger werden jetzt
wieder neu
produziert und ist eigentlich etwas dass
man typisch also das typisch ist für
diesen Krieg dass man sagt wir haben
eigentlich ältere Technologie
Bestandteile also attackems z.B die ja
letzten Herbst gekommen sind auch die
sind jetzt nicht gerade neu sondern
stammen eigentlich aus den 90er Jahren
und
diese diese Bestandteile sind eigentlich
im Wesentlichen abgeschrieben das heißt
man kann die also zu sehr günstigen
haushaltskondition quasi aus den aus den
Department of Defense stocks entnehmen
und entspre chend hinschicken und jetzt
nachdem was was Frau newland erzählt hat
sind die bereits in der Ukraine das hat
sie vor glaub vor 24 Stunden erzählt
also müssten wir jetzt eigentlich heute
oder morgen die Ankunft dann sehen an
der Front und dann in der nächsten Tagen
auch schon den den ersten Einsatz okay
die sind also in der Theorie gut reichen
durchaus weit es gibt auch genug es
werden genug produziert wissen wir denn
wie viel davon gelief wird das ist ja
aktuell noch nicht ganz klar also wird
diese ganze Kapazität auch wirklich dann
in der Ukraine
mündenm also ich ich denke der der große
Vorteil ist eben wir haben hier es nicht
wie bei attackems oder wie bei Taurus es
zu tun mit mit sehr
teuren Systemen oder mit mit Systemen wo
eben nur wenige hundert überhaupt zur
Verfügung stehen also die globalen
gesamtvorräte von der tagem sind eben
wenige 100 Stück ne und das gleiche
stückzahlprem haben wir ja auch schon
diskutiert bei Storm shadow bei bei
scalp bei Taurus besteht das nicht so
sehr da haben wir vielleicht 500 im
Moment aber trotzdem sie sehen die
Größenordnung ne x 100 versus X1000 bzw
x10000 und
insofern
würde ich sagen ich ich kenne die
konkreten lieferzahlen noch nicht aber
es besteht hier jedenfalls kein kein
nachschubproblem oder kein Problem das
in in sehr großen Stückzahlen zu liefern
es wird wahrscheinlich so ablaufen wie
bei attackems die Ukraine bekommt
erstmal ein Teil führt Proof of Concept
durch das heißt zeigt dass sie damit
umgehen kann dass sie damit wertvolle
Ziele erreichen kann und sobald das der
Fall ist ähm wird es sicher ein ein
großes Problem der Ukraine lösen nämlich
äh den den artilleriemangel bei der
klassischen Artillerie ne auch das muss
man immer ein bisschen auseinanderhalten
artilleriemangel besteht bei klassischen
artilleri geschossen nicht aber äh bei
raketenartillerie nicht ähm bei drohen
die teilweise die Artillerie
substituieren und ganz sicher nicht hier
bei glsdb also es ist es ist eine große
ähm eine große Verstärkung ähm der der
raketenartillerie und eine die
sicherlich starke Auswirkung haben wird
auf die russischen nachschubliniie also
diese die gsdb ist ist zwar sehr präzise
sie hat eine circular eror probability
von etwa 1 mer und sie kann auch schwere
Strukturen durchbrechen also 1 m
stahbeton kann sie kann sie durchbrechen
aber wichtiger für die Ukraine wäre es
natürlich den russischen Nachschub zu
unterbinden ne also so dass nichts mehr
an die fronte durchkommt genau hier
sehen wir gerade so ein so ein Bild ähm
also das das ist schon eine sehr potente
Waffe sie sie ist wie gesagt sehr leicht
sie trägt nur sehr sehr geringe ähm
Sprengladung ich glaube von etwa 16 kg
ähm aber sie richtet damit ziemlich
großen Schaden an wir sehen hier
übrigens auch die gleitflügel ähm die da
ausfahren al das muss man auch wissen
das Ding ist eine sogenannte gleitbombe
also sobald der Raketenmotor das Ding
ähm quasi in rauskatapultiert hat fällt
der ab das Ding teilt sich die Flügel
klappen aus und dann gleitet die in ihr
Ziel das heißt also sie hat keine
Infrarot signignatur
sie muss nicht irgendwie gesteuert
werden
sie kann auch mit mit reiner
trägheitsnavigation fliegen und das
heißt die ist durch electronic Warfare
sehr schwer zu erkennen oder abzufangen
ne also insofern es ist eigentlich was
was sehr innovatives
und und etwas das glaube ich jetzt
deutlich mehr Wirkung erzielen wird als
als klassische
jetzt sind ja aber gerade noch die
Ukrain Hilfen in den USA finanziell
blockiert
ja aber da da geht's um was anderes also
da da müssen Sie bitte auch immer
unterscheiden handelt es sich hier um
presidential dradan authority oder
handelt es sich um supplementary
appropriation also spricht das letztere
supplementary appropriation das muss
durch den Kongress aber da geht's nicht
darum dass irgendwie der Ukraine Bargeld
geschickt wird sondern da geht's vor
allem darum
die amerikanische
Verteidigungsindustrie anzuwerfen ne
also spricht die den Verträge zu geben
äh womit dann das Department of Defense
wieder beginnt neue Waffen zu
produzieren während man die alten
Bestände aus den Lagern in die Ukraine
schickt aber
Boeing und und SAB haben diesen Auftrag
erhalten also für für die
Produktionslinie
und also soweit ich weiß gibt's da keine
finanzierungspreme also außer sie wissen
jetzt mehr als
ich nee wir gucken mal wie sich das
weiterentwickelt und kommen mal zu einem
weiteren Teil der Ausstattung nämlich
zum Artillerie Munitionsmangel der wird
ja dieser Tage auch viel beschrieben es
wird gesagt das ist eine große
Herausforderung die für die Ukraine sie
kann im Durchschnitt viel weniger
verschießen als Russland jetzt ist
gestern bei dem eutreffen ja auch noch
rausgekommen diese eine Million Schuss
Artilleriemunition die man da letztes
Jahr mal versprochen hatte die kann man
nicht einhalten jetzt fragen sich viele
wie lange kann die Ukraine diesen Mangel
noch aushalten ja ja wissen sie das das
Thema artilleriemangel das ist so immer
so ein to schlagargument das stimmt so
also in manchen Bereichen aber man man
kann das nicht so global sagen ich muss
dazu wie immer etwas ausholen also
Vorsicht wir überziehen jetzt
m also zunächst mal muss man
unterscheiden über welche Art von
Artillerie man spricht wenn man über
klassische Artillerie spricht also
spricht die die aus schweren Geschützen
abgefeuert wird
ja da hat die Ukraine viel zu wenig das
stimmt das ist aber ein bekanntes
Problem seit Kriegsbeginn ähm man muss
aber auch sagen auch die feuerfquenz der
russischen Truppen ist stark gesunken
also von noch etwa 50.000 pro Tag im
Sommer 22 das war so das Maximum als sie
Sever Don erobert haben auf jetzt noch
etwa 10.000 pro Tag und die russische
die die ukrainische Frequenz liegt so je
nach Frontabschnitt zwischen 2000 und
5000 pro Tag ähm wir reden jetzt aber
hier über klassische
Artillerie also das was wir hier gerade
sehen ne also die aus aus solchen
klassischen schweren Geschützen
abgefeuert wird es gibt aber auch noch
andere Arten von Artillerie also
insbesondere klustermunition also
depckem dort besteht keine keine
Knappheit an depickem geschossen und wir
reden natürlich auch über
raketenartillerie und ja da muss man
natürlich sparsam umgehen mit attackems
und mit Heß weil es davon nicht so viele
gibt aber eben das was ich gerade
erklärt habe
glsdb ist erstmals ein
raketenartilleriesystem das nicht
nicht knapp ist dass man also auch in
größeren Stückzahlen oder in größerer
Massierung
verfeuern kann man muss auch sehen
russland hat natürlich ein einen großen
artillerievorteil gehabt als sie in
diesen Krieg hineingegangen sind dass
etwa 17 Millionen Artillerie Granaten
das waren die kombinierten sowjetischen
und russischen Bestände von denen sind
jetzt etwa 12 Millionen Weg ne also das
das Problem Artillerie Mangel bzw
nachflug das kommt natürlich auch auf
die russischen Produktionskapazitäten zu
und das ist ja das was ich immer sage
wir sehen bisher den Krieg immer mit
einer Verzerrung ne wir denken grussland
ist ist stark aber bisher kämpft
Russland diesen Krieg im Wesentlichen
aus seinen Reserven also die
historischen Reserven die Russland
einsetzen kann die sind viel viel größer
als seine tatsächliche
Produktionskapazität und erst wenn diese
ganzen historischen Reserven verschossen
bzw abgenutzt sind erst dann wird die
russische Rüstungsindustrie wirklich
getestet und erst dann können wir
wirklich beobachten wie ist eigentlich
das
nachschubpotenzial Russlands es soll die
Problematik natürlich nicht beschönigen
wir erinnern uns vielleicht noch an den
Sommer 22 wie lange das dauert hat bis
man gewisse westliche Staaten dazu
überreden konnte dass die Ukraine
Artillerie braucht das hat also bis in
den Sommer 22 gedauert ne wir waren
damals noch ein zum anderen Level und
haben uns damals noch Illusionen
hingegeben manche tun das bis heute aber
wenn sie dran denken was da was man
damals hätte machen können ne wenn man
damals die Ukraine massiv mit Artillerie
ausgestattet hat gut hätte hätte
Fahrradkette ne man braucht nicht über
über diese diese Dinge diskutieren weil
sie in der verg Vergangenheit liegen
aber trotzdem muss man sich fragen na ja
wenn die EU das jetzt nicht mal
hinkriegt eine Million Granaten pro Jahr
zu schaffen wie wie wollen Sie das dann
machen wenn also angenommen Russland den
Krieg gewinnt und und dann an der
natogrenze steht also ich meine da
sollten Sie mal drüber nachdenken ne
also Europa ist ist nicht im geringsten
vorbereitet auf so eine Konfrontation
und täte gut daran
seine seine Potenziale so langsam mal zu
aktivieren ich glaube viele haben noch
nicht wirklich verstanden
dass wir uns hier in einer welthorischen
Auseinandersetzung befinden in der es
wirklich um um den Kern der Sache geht
also bis hin zur eigenen staatlichen
Existenz sie können sie können zum Glück
sagen dass die Ukraine im Moment die
Front hält ne weil sonst wä nämlich
Duster sie können zum Glück sagen dass
Polen aufrüstet sonst wä nämlich Duster
also in in dem Kontext muss man das
ganze auch mal sehen es geht jetzt hier
nicht nur um irgendwelche
Produktionszahlen die Sie hier nicht
getroffen haben sondern es es geht
letztlich um die Frage wie glaubwürdig
sind Sie bei der abstchreckung
Russlands ja und hier haben wir auch
noch ziemlich viele Nachfragen um jetzt
mal wieder so ins kleinere um in die
kleineren Fragen zu kommen äh nach den
F16 Jets wann werden sie in der Ukraine
eintreffen und was ändert sich wenn sie
da sind mhm also nach derzeitiger
Planung im Frühjahr ähm also vermutlich
März April
ähm was ändert sich dann na ja äh das
größte Problem der Ukraine ist im Moment
dass die Russen relativ ungestraft im
frontraum mit luftmitteln operieren
können das heißt also mit
Kampfhubschraubern und mit eigenen äh
Kampfflugzeugen ähm das heißt die
Ukrainer werden zunächst mal in der Lage
ähm größere Hoheit über ihr eigenes
Frontgebiet zu gewinnen also z.B den
Russen nicht mehr zu gestatten dass sie
die Front einfach so bombardieren können
ähm sie können stärker ihren eigenen
Luftraum überwachen das heißt es wird
für Russland schwieriger seine
Terrorangriffe äh auf die Städte und die
zivilen Infrastrukturen äh durchzuführen
also mit diesen wahlosen Bombardements
die es im Moment relativ ungestraft
betreiben kann ähm und natürlich steigt
ihr angriffsradius ne also wenn Sie wenn
Sie sie
Kampfflugzeug eben starten lassen sagen
wir mal aus der Region Odessa einmal
rüber fliegen auf die Krim und einmal
wieder zurück dann eröffnet Ihnen das
natürlich neue strategische
Möglichkeiten Russland anzugreifen und
ähm es ist ja das was was man immer
gesagt hat ja die die die Ukraine kann
das nicht bedienen oder die brauchen zu
lange also nein das sie sehen das das
ist durchaus möglich und die Leute
trainieren und beherrschen das System
auch und auch da zeigt sich wieder was
ich vorhin gesagt habe ne wenn man
früher angefangen hätte stärker
hineinzugehen und zu sagen das ist jetzt
nicht hier so ein bisschen hinauszögern
oder die Ukraine darf nicht verlieren
sondern das ist eine welthistorische
Auseinandersetzung mit Russland und
entweder entweder sagen wir jetzt hier
ist die Grenze ne oder oder wir machen
weiter Appeasement ich ich hoffe man hat
das jetzt so langsam mal eingesehen also
die die Frage ist nicht ob kampflugzeug
oder nicht oder ob mehr Artillerie oder
oder nicht die Frage ist Artillerie ja
sofort die Frage ist Kampfflugzeug ja
sofort ne also das versetzt die Ukraine
eigentlich erst in die Lage überhaupt
ein Mal gleichzuziehen mit den
russischen Möglichkeiten was was sie
bisher eben nicht konnte und wird sie
dann letztlich vielleicht in die Lage
versehen versetzen also sagen wir mal
vielleicht Ende diesen Jahres erstmals
wieder mobil vorzurücken also sprich mit
mit stärkerer Luftunterstützung dann
auch
wieder in die mobile Kampfführung
überzugehen
in Anbetracht der Zeit machen wir mal
jetzt sowas wie eine
ja im in unserem Sinne kurz Fragerunde
es gibt nämlich noch einige Fragen zu
Russland es wird hier gefragt nach den
Kapazitäten nach den militärischen
Kapazitäten der Russen und es wird
gefragt hat Russland in den nächsten
Monaten genug Kapazitäten um eine
Großoffensive zu starten wie steht es
denn um deren Ausstattung mm ja das
hängt davon ab was Sie mit Großoffensive
meinen also die einsatzfähige
Panzerwaffe von den etwa 3000 ne von
denen ich früher immer gesprochen habe
die ist fast weg also wir sind jetzt auf
2700 Kampf Panzern die weg sind
ähm tja die Produktionskapazität beträgt
also Produktion müssen man in
Anführungszeichen betrachten ne also das
heißt vor allem Instandsetzung älterer
Systeme die aus den Lagern gezogen
werden aber ich würde schätzen
vielleicht 150 bis 200 maximal pro Monat
ähm das reicht ihnen vielleicht gerade
um die derzeitige Abschlussquote ähm
auszugleichen aber das reicht ihnen
nicht um Reserven zu massieren also
dafür müssen sie wirklich massiv in die
Lage hineingehen aber das tun sie ja
schon seit Kriegsbeginn also wenn sie
mit Großoffensive meinen entlang des
gesamten frontbogens
quasi um um die ukrainische Front
zusammenzuschieben würde ich sagen nein
weil wenn das möglich wäre dann hätten
sie es längst getan das was ich immer
sage wenn die russische Armee so
großartig ist wieso macht sie nicht
einfach eine Großoffensive und rollt die
Ukrain einfach auf ne wieso gibt sie
sich so viel Mühe und und stellt sich so
dumm an
ähm also wirklich glaubwürdig ist das
nicht nein äh dafür bräuchten sie eine
ganz andere logistische und industrielle
Kapazität ich glaube nicht dass Russland
die im Moment zur Verfügung hat mein
Statement ist nach wie vor und
unverändert Russland führt den Krieg aus
seinen Reserven solange die Reserven
groß sind geht das gut je Stärke sie
abschmelzen desto weniger geht das gut
also ich ich glaube das nicht wirklich
und wir haben jetzt zum Abschluss noch
eine Frage von einem Zuschauer der die
Sendung auch mit ihnen öfter zu schauen
scheint er fragt nämlich russland hatte
den Krieg im letzten Oktober bereits
strategisch verloren gibt es ihrer
Meinung nach im weiteren Verlauf noch
weitere entscheidende Zeitpunkte worauf
wir achten sollten ja also sicher der
Zeitpunkt wenn Kampflugzeuge zum ersten
Mal eingesetzt werden ähm also der in
diesem Frühjahr und ähm sie sollten eben
äh schauen auf die abnutzungsrate ne
also wenn die einsatzfähigen Reserven
Russlands wirklich weg sind äh und
Russland gezwungen sein wird erstmals
offen zu legen wie leistungsfähig seine
Rüstungsindustrie äh sein wird ähm und
ab dann denke ich wird der Krieg einen
anderen Verlauf nehmen bis dahin wird er
denke ich im Wesentlichen statisch
bleiben ja ich denke wir werden uns zu
dem Thema sicher noch mal sprechen Herr
Kolb vielen Dank dass sie da waren und
einen schönen Abend noch gerne schönen
Abend und auch euch danke ich für eure
zahlreichen Fragen und Kommentare ich
freue mich wenn ihr wieder einschaltet
zur nächsten ZDF heute liveesendung
vielleicht ja auch zum nächsten Ukraine
Update schönen Abend euch
noch